[Music]
good to see you again
good to see you what's happening what do
we got what's going on i can't wait to
hear
i'm still at it you know i i i lose
sleep at night thinking i gotta tell
this to chuck
okay just so you know i'm thinking i
don't i don't believe that
i don't believe that for one second
but i'll take it i will take it i just
got to straighten some things out
okay i think they
some people not everybody but some
people i think have this all confused
and i want to straighten it out
all right it's the difference between
mass weight
and density all right well okay now for
without a doubt there are there's a lot
of people that get that confused i just
want
okay so generally if you go on a diet
you want to lose weight right
absolutely so what that's not what
actually what's actually happening
it is but it's not the root of what's
happening
what you're really doing is you're
losing mass
you want there to be less of you
tomorrow than there is today
if only i could keep the parts that i
want
if if you consume fewer calories
today then you burned calories today
you will lose weight okay it's that
simple
okay i i've joked about this a a weight
loss book
written by a physicist would have one
sentence
consume calories at a slower rate
than you burn them that's the entire
that's it but so if tomorrow you want
less of you than there is today you're
losing mass
okay the mass is the sum of all the
particles that comprise
chuck okay that's your mass
i could take you and put you on the moon
you'll weigh less but you still have all
of your particles
okay then that is where i need to move
when can we do this
so if you weigh 180 pounds i don't know
how much you weigh let's call you 180
pounds on earth
okay on the moon you weigh one-sixth of
that right so
you weigh 30 pounds so chuck you want to
lose 150 pounds
your nutrition will say no chuck you'll
die no i'm just going to go to the moon
for a day
weigh myself i'm 150 so your weight
is not itself the measure of how much
mass you have
okay all right you also weigh a little
less at the top of a mountain because
you're farther away from the center of
the earth
than you do in death valley where you're
at a low point
relative to other places on earth so if
you get on a scale at the top of everest
you're going to weigh
less than you would on that same scale
in death valley
in death correct okay less okay people
at the equator
weigh a little less than they would if
they're visiting santa claus
oh that's there's a lot of sun down
there and they got to stay in bikini
shape all year long
that's fine right that's really what
it's about so
oh for another we do another explainer
video why there's actually very little
sun
on the equator okay it's it's one of the
that fact that's where you find your
greatest rain forest um sun is not
happening
on the equator but that's a whole lot of
conversation it's a that's a climactic
conversation we will have i promise all
right so
so but i get your sentiment it's
it's south it's south and it's warm it's
warm all right
so so the equator is the speed at which
you are moving
is faster than at other latitudes people
on equator moving about a thousand miles
an hour
we here in new york we're moving about
800 miles an hour
so that centrifugal force makes them
lighter than we are
gotcha so all of this is affecting your
weight but it's not affecting your mass
okay so if you want to lose weight in
any zone
then lose mass all right
just to be clear about that all right so
weight loss programs are actually mass
loss programs
okay and so weight then is
is about forces then it's not it's not
about
it's the definition of weight wait is
the force of gravity on you
well who's gravity are we talking about
earth or this or or the sun or venus or
the moon
so you find out what is what are the
conditions of that force of gravity on
you in that place
not only among planets but even
different places on earth
and then you've got your weight
and that weight is related to how many
molecules of truck exist
but in the end of the day if you want to
weigh less what you really mean is you
want less mass you want less
chuck tomorrow than you have today so
just want to put that out there
something better right everybody can
agree on that let's check tomorrow
[Laughter]
we don't we don't show you the the mails
we the mail we get
um when will chuck disappear
we will hold those from you right okay
so
now we talk about how heavy something is
okay okay so when we think of something
floating on water
generally the idea of it being heavy is
not
that's not the same thought correct no
of course
if it's heavy it sinks okay so now
let's take let's take
uh you know uh you know let's go to
who's the guy
who splits wood sections
into firewood uh whatever that is okay
go take one of these bunion guys
paul bunyan cylinders of wood okay
it's gonna be really heavy we know this
take it
plunk it down in a swimming pool what
happens to it it floats it floats
even though it's super heavy okay it is
heavy
but it floats right okay so
how do you get around that what do we
let's let's give more examples of that
okay um ivory soap
nobody who's what okay yes
ivory soap floats right and as far as i
know it's the only soap that floats i
did an experiment when i was younger but
i haven't checked
lately but i did test this yeah ivory
soap floats all the others
so same okay okay so why that should be
a selling point
i don't know but it was in its day it
was a selling point
and then it was it was 88 100 percent
purer right and it was like pure what
right exactly you know i i remember
thinking as a kid but any every so
long predates me but i remember thinking
all that all right
so heavy cream
is lighter than skim milk
heavy cream is lighter than skim
milk and you know why because it floats
on the skim milk
that's how you get skim milk there you
go
the cream floats between rises to the
top you skim it off
you got some heavy cream so we say it's
heavier but we don't really
mean heavier heavier to me is the
absolute weight how heavy is it can i
pick it up
what we mean is thinner with with no
it's not thinner
well it's more less viscous less dense
okay this viscosity is no i should have
added that we'll get to viscosity in a
minute
okay heavy cream is less dense
than water than skim milk right
if you are less dense than something
else you float there you go there it is
nothing else nothing else matters right
okay you will float so heavy cream
is we would say it's lighter than skim
milk
but that's a little deceptive if you
want to be precise you say it's less
dense than skim milk and therefore it
floats
okay so this is the fight i was in a
fight the encounter i had in a pasadena
coffee shop
when i ordered hot chocolate with
whipped cream and the hot chocolate came
and there's no whipped cream anywhere to
be found and i said um
server where is the whipped cream they
said oh we put it on i said where is it
oh it must have sunk to the bottom
at which point i said either
you are lying or the laws of physics
that apply to the rest of the universe
do not apply in your coffee shop
and so he got all gruffy and he went by
and brought cream with him
okay and then plunked it down and it
took one bob
and instead of and it floated i said
thank you for my whipped cream
mm-hmm now i don't know if that became
like a story
you know because i'm sure wait staff
tell stories
right but that's what happened so he's
thinking
it's heavy it probably fell to the
bottom and would choose to lie
and rather lie about it thinking that i
didn't know what the hell i was talking
about
and when you took it away you looked at
him and you went
science [ __ ]
you just got scienced you just got
scienced
science so
a couple more things about weight mass
and
density so
um
you realize that logs float all right
right if you're gonna say if i want it
but i don't float very well
all right so if i want to float on the
water
i'm going to use a log so why don't i
get a big log and then hollow it out
okay okay these are the first canoes
right
okay the canoes are made of wood you hot
and you know the canoe is going to float
i'm going to get in it and we're good to
go
well why don't you make a boat out of
steel
well i can't do that because the steel
will sink that's not a boat
that's not going to work no let's be
clever about it
okay by the way if you make a boat out
of steel is then impervious
to the weapons of other boats oh my gosh
what a military advance this would be
this
in the 19th century i think it was where
the first
people figured out i can make a boat out
of things that are impervious
to cannonballs right and so whereas if
you make a boat out of wood
then it just busts through the wood
right so
what matters is not the density of the
material
what matters is the density of
everything that is sitting below water
so if i create a hull
only the outer edge of the hole is made
of steel
what's everything else inside the hull
made out of
something else no uh
it's air air air it's a
it's like a ballast okay no no ballast
has a different purpose right because
you want to stabilize
okay so you put some other you put some
heavy things just at the very bottom
of the hull and that keeps okay position
and that keep that keeps the that keeps
it in positions that would be ballast
okay and a lot of the cobblestone in
lower manhattan that built the roads
was balanced in ships that came from
europe
okay and then they offload that and
build built roads with it
sweet yeah yeah so a lot of it no and
other
things as well but point is you
so now the the density
is what is the total mass divided by the
total volume
okay so that's grams per cubic
centimeter or pounds per cubic inch
that's
that's so those are the units of density
so let me get some units out there so
we've got the units of mass
or grams and kilograms and i'm not going
to tell you the unit of mass
for the english system okay and the unit
he's supposed to say why not tell me
why not no
so seriously what is why wouldn't you
give out the uh
okay the unit of mass in the english
system
is slug no yes that's why i told you i
told you not to ask me so
yeah so so the mass grams kilograms this
sort of thing
volume is the cubic of some of some
length so cubic inch
cubic centimeter cubic meter those are
flames density
is the mass divided by the volume mass
divided by volume
okay so just see how that works so if i
have a certain amount of mass and i put
it in a smaller and smaller volume
it becomes more and more dense yeah yeah
so what happens that if
the denominator gets smaller then the
number gets bigger bigger so we get
higher and higher density because you're
cramming all this into a smaller volume
right the volume gets bigger and bigger
and bigger for the same amount of mass
right then the density gets lower and
lower and lower you get beach balls
another right you're spreading it out
spreading out so what i've done with the
steel
is i've put air in between the two steel
sides of the boat so now the density the
effective density
is the mass of the steel plus the mass
of the air divided by the volume
and when i do that i get something
that's less dense than water and the
whole thing floats so then it goes it
will only go down
a certain amount in the water certain
amount that's it that's it and it
but it will float that's how you make
boats out of steel
and that's how military ships were first
put together
i mean cool the the the indestructible
type right so then you needed a weapon
that could destroy the steel and then
you have the
the eternal contest of warring arms rays
arms race
exactly exactly so so
that there you have it chuck so so we
have mass density so anything that
floats on water
is simply less dense than water right it
doesn't matter how much it weighs
or what it is it just has to be less
dense than water
does nothing else matters wow that's
cool
and it could weigh a zillion pounds and
it'll just it'll still flow
which is why my uncle edward floats
that's a big man that's a fat brother
i'm telling you oh he's a big fat buddy
well so so fat is less dense than than
water and bones
and muscle is more dense so if you float
every time you just have way more fat
than
muscle and bone well there you have it
good for you
uncle eddie
that's why it's no accident that that
marine
mammals have a lot of fat right okay the
blubber like as they call it right
so there's a lot of fat there and that
gives them buoyancy
in the water yes all right oh by the way
what's an ice cube made out of
water but why do they float
because they have air inside of them i
don't know no well sometimes they do but
that's not oh no they expand
they expand it's less dense right so
it's less dense the water the water it
used to be
now takes up more volume right so bigger
vine makes it less than some ice floats
there you go you know we should do an
explainer on ice expanding we should do
that
we should do that not now not now we're
going to oh why not well no i guess
we're done
we're done here we're done here all
right well looking forward to ice
expanding there okay
thanks for doing this with me chuck of
course always a pleasure neil degrasse
tyson here for star call
keep looking up
you